da kommt er direkt aus rio vorher london
new york
für uns hat alessandro aller wähler
genau eine stunde
bitte kein vorgespräch blabla loslegen
wer nichts weiß braucht keine angst zu
haben
aus starten wir in jedes unsere projekt
das innovation center der universität
santiago de chile ein bürokomplex mit
nach innen gestülpte form erdacht von
arena statt der üblichen glasfassade
eine betonhülle mit lichtschächten
verhindert das treibhausklima ihnen
dafür alles verglast kommunikativ und
energiesparend klimaanlagen sind
überflüssig zwei drittel weniger
energieverbrauch
wenn man alles mit einer strikten
ignoranz heran geht kann man jede menge
dumme fragen stellen und neue ansätze zu
finden
selbst für bereiche die schon tausend
mal bearbeitet wurde bei denen man das
gefühl hat man kann nichts mehr
hinzufügen
weltberühmt wurde er mit anti bombast
sozialer wohnungsbau
der chilenische staat gab ihm den
auftrag günstigen wohnraum zu schaffen
mit kleinstem budget weniger als 10.000
euro pro wohnung für bau und grund wir
haben uns gefragt wenn man mit dem lasso
raus etwa 80 quadratmeter hat das geld
aber gerade mal nur für 40 quadratmeter
reicht warum bauen wir da nicht statt
eines kleinen schlechten hauses lieber
ein halbes gutes
die idee halb fertig gebaute häuser über
2000 gibt es in chile bereits dach ein
zimmer küche und bad sind vorhanden den
rest können die einwohner selbst
ausbauen oder als terrasse benutzen
individuelles holzdesign stadt sozial
blog einheitsbrei jeder von uns der ein
haus kauft erwartet doch dass es mit der
zeit im wert steigt aber leider ist es
bei sozialwohnungen so wie bei autos der
wert sinkt deswegen wollen wir bei den
häusern sichergehen dass sie für die
bewohner eine gewinnbringende anlage
sind eine investition nicht einfach eine
soziale aufgabe arena kommt aus einer
lehrerfamilie das architektur diplom
macht er weil er gut in mathe und physik
ist nach wenigen jahren schließt er
vorübergehend sein büro eröffnet eine
bar zu frustrierend alles
ich hatte echt beschissen bauherren
ihnen ging es nur darum schnelles geld
zu machen extrem eigennützig und dazu
dieser furchtbar mittelmäßige anspruch
wenn man von menschen in slums arbeitet
ist das anders
sie können zwar vielleicht nicht lesen
und schreiben aber sie haben diese
sehnsucht nach architektur und einem
guten leben
konstitution an der pazifikküste seine
bisher größte herausforderung nach dem
tsunami 2010 waren 80 prozent der stadt
zerstört
100 tage hatte arenas bürozeit um einen
masterplan für den wiederaufbau zu
entwerfen
er diskutierte trotzdem wochenlang mit
den bürgern
während dieser bürgerbeteiligung
erklärten mir die menschen natürlich
sind wir froh dass thorenz vor tsunamis
schützen will aber der nächste wird
wahrscheinlich ersten 20 bis 30 jahren
kommen
viel drängender für uns ist dass die das
problem löst dass wir mit der
überschwemmung durch den regen
jeden winter bricht hier alles zusammen
darum wird nun an der küste eine
parkanlage gebaut mit einem wald der
saugt das regenwasser auf bremst die
tsunami wellen ab schafft mehr freie
flächen für die bürger und arena
gegenüber seinen auftrag hinaus
koordinierte förderprogramme und sparte
so millionen
jetzt kann sich die stadt sogar noch ein
kulturzentrum und eine bibliothek
leisten
die stadt war vor dem erdbeben zwar
nicht tot aber es war wenig los
jetzt ist sie wieder richtig lebendig
die fundamente der gebäude sind jetzt
viel besser
und im augenblick alles ist stabil die
große kraft der architektur liegt in der
synthese wenn wir alle kräfte bündeln
die menschen die natur die politik dann
haben wir das potenzial eine große idee
zu entwickeln
alexandra arena findet auf die
schwierigsten fragen unserer zeit genial
einfache antworten konsequent dass er
nun die architekturbiennale in venedig
leitet ab kommendem wochenende